AMERICANS I WENT TO EUROPE TO
MEET WITH WHAT THEY CALL THE
G7 --
>> Greg: ALL RIGHT.
PRESIDENT BIDEN IN
NORTH CAROLINA ENCOURAGING
AMERICANS TO GET VACCINATED.
WAS IT RUDE?
YOU'VE NEVER BEEN RUDE, GERALDO,
SPEND YOUR DECADES DUCKING
CHAIRS.
YESTERDAY THE PRESIDENT BLAMED
GUNS AND NOT CRIMINALS FOR THE
SURGE IN CRIME, THE RISE IN
VIOLENCE IS BECAUSE OF THE
WEATHER AND THEN PRESIDENT BIDEN
MOCKED THE SECOND AMENDMENT.
>> THE SECOND AMENDMENT FROM THE
DAY IT WAS TASKED, LIMITED THE
TYPE OF PEOPLE WHO COULD OWN
GONE AND WHAT TYPE OF WEAPON YOU
COULD OWN, YOU NEEDED TO HAVE
WEAPONS TO TAKE ON THE
GOVERNMENT, F-15s AND MAYBE
SOME NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
>> Greg: KATIE, HE WAS TALKING
ABOUT HOW SILLY THE IDEA IS OF
HAVING THE SECOND AMENDMENT TO
PROTECT AGAINST A HOSTILE
GOVERNMENT OR WHATEVER, THIS IS
AFTER, I DON'T KNOW, A FEW WEEKS
SINCE HE CLAIMED THAT A FEW
HUNDRED MAGA PROTESTERS WERE THE
WORST THREAT TO DEMOCRACY SINCE
THE CIVIL WAR.
WHAT'S GOING TO BE?
>> Katie: HE'S TRYING TO SAY
BOTH, THREATENING GUN OWNERS BUT
IF YOU DARE TO EXERCISE THE
SECOND AMENDMENT OR STAND UP FOR
YOUR RIGHTS THE GOVERNMENT MAY
NUKE YOU WHICH IS A WEIRD
POSITION TO TAKE IT AT THE SAME
TIME PEOPLE WHO ARE UNARMED WHO
WENT TO THE CAPITAL ON
JANUARY 6TH ARE ALSO CAPABLE,
WITH NOTHING TO TAKE OVER THE
GOVERNMENT.
THAT ARGUMENT DOESN'T FLY.
THE ARGUMENT HE'S TRYING TO MAKE
IS VERY OUT OF TOUCH WITH THE
CURRENT SITUATION WHEN IT COMES
TO FIREARMS.
FIRST-TIME BUYERS LAST YEAR, 45%
OF THEM WERE WOMEN, MORE THAN
50% OF THEM ARE
AFRICAN-AMERICANS, THE LEFT IS
LOSING THIS ARGUMENT, THEY ARE
TRYING TO CONTINUE THIS
NARRATIVE OF THE ONLY PEOPLE WHO
BUY BACKGROUNDS AND A WHITE
SUPREMACIST WHICH IS NOT TRUE OR
SUPPORTED BY THE DATA AND TO THE
BOTTOM LINE IS THEY ARE BUYING
GUNS TO PROTECT THEMSELVES FROM
CRIMINALS BECAUSE ALL OF THESE
PEOPLE WHO ARE IN CHARGE OF
DEMOCRATIC CITIES ARE TAKING
AWAY THEIR POLICE SO THERE IS
OUR LAST OFFENSE AND OUR ONLY
DEFENSE AND THEY ARE TRYING TO
MAKE SURE THEY HAVE THE RIGHT
BECAUSE THEY ARE ON A TOUGH
SITUATION WITH THE CRIME RIGHT
NOW.
>> Greg: LAST NIGHT WE SAW AN
ATTACK ON A POLICE STATION AFTER
DRUG DEALERS WERE ARRESTED, I
THINK IT WAS IN NORTH CAROLINA,
RIGHT?
THESE ARE THINGS THE DEMOCRATS
IGNORE AS THEY RELEASE LOOTERS
AND DECIDE THEY ARE NOT GOING TO
CHARGE PEOPLE WHO ARE RIOTING
BUT THE GOOD NEWS IS WE WERE
ABLE TO GET, WE WERE ABLE TO
SENTENCE A GRANDMOTHER, AND
INDIANA GRANDMOTHER FOR ENTERING
THE CAPITAL ON JANUARY 6.
120 HOURS OF COMMUNITY SERVICE.
SHE GOT 120 MORE HOURS THAN
HUNTER BIDEN DID FOR VIOLATING A
GUN LAW.
>> Jesse: GERALDO SAID SHE HAD
IT COMING, YOU ARE TOUGH,
GERALDO.
>> Katie: TEN YEARS IN PRISON,
A FELONY AND NOBODY'S TALKING
ABOUT IT.
>> Jesse: JOE BIDEN SAYS THE
F-15 THING, THAT'S A STRAWMAN
ARGUMENT HE GOT FROM BARACK.
REMEMBER BARACK SAID, WHAT DO
YOU NEED A BAZOOKA FOR?
YOU ARE DOING THAT TO TRY TO
MAKE THE OTHER SIDE LOOK CRAZY.
YOU ARE CRAZY IF YOU WANT TO
PROTECT YOURSELF?
>> Geraldo: WHAT YOU NEED A
BAZOOKA FOR?
>> Jesse: NO ONE NEEDS A
BAZOOKA, THAT'S A POINT, YOU
JUST FELL FOR THE STRAWMAN
ARGUMENT.
THEY WILL BAIL OUT DERANGED
HOMICIDAL MANIACS, WHAT YOU NEED
A GUN FOR?
BLM COMES TO THEIR HOOD AND
STARTS YELLING AT THEM, YOU'RE
GOING TO GET INDICTED BY A
DEMOCRAT.
WE NEED GUNS BECAUSE WE DON'T
TRUST THE CRIMINALS AND WE DON'T
TRUST THE GUNMAN, NOT
NECESSARILY IN THAT ORDER AND
THAT'S WHY IT DEMOCRATS DON'T
LIKE THAT, WE ARE SELF-RELIANT
AND WE DON'T RELY ON THEM.
>> Greg: THEY HAD TO TURN IN
THEIR GUNS, THE MOMENT THEY
TURNED THEM IN, I THINK THE
ISSUE HERE IS THEY CAN'T
IDENTIFY THE PROBLEM BECAUSE IT
GOES RIGHT BACK TO THE CAUSE
WHICH IS THEIR POLICIES.
>> Geraldo: THE
SECOND AMENDMENT AS CURRENTLY
CONSTRUED AND EVEN PEOPLE WHO
LOVE ME GET MAD AT ME, IT'S
STUPID.
AFRICAN-AMERICAN WOMEN BUYING
PISTOLS, BUT WHAT DO WE NEED
AR-15s FOR?
YOU CAN'T HUNT WITH THEM.
>> Jesse: I HAVE HUNTED WITH
ONE!
>> Geraldo: I DON'T KNOW WHAT
YOU ARE HUNTING.
PRESIDENT BIDEN TOLD THE JOKE
BADLY YESTERDAY ABOUT THE DEER
WEARING KEVLAR AND APPARENTLY
FORGOT HE HAD TOLD THE JOKE AND
TOLD THE SAME JOKE.
>> Katie: HE FORGOT?
>> Geraldo: I THINK THESE
HEAVY WEAPON SHOULD HAVE THE
SAME KIND OF REQUIREMENTS FOR
QUALIFICATION AS DRIVING A
TRUCK.
SOME INSTRUCTION ABOUT WHAT IT
IS YOU ARE BUYING.
>> Katie: THERE ARE MORE
PEOPLE KILLED EVERY YEAR BY HAND
IN FIST AND HAMMERS THAN
AR-15s.
>> Greg: THIS IS NOT HAVING
ANY DENT IN WHAT WE ARE
EXPERIENCING IN THIS MASSIVE
SPIKE.
>> Geraldo: I AGREE WITH THAT
BUT THAT'S NOT THE STORY.
>> Greg: DAY NOW, THERE WAS
SOMETHING HE SAID YESTERDAY.
HE WAS SAYING THERE WERE
CRIMINALS LIVING UNDER BRIDGES
AND THAT WAS THE PROBLEM,
CRIMINALS LIVING UNDER BRIDGES.
>> Dana: WE NEED TO HAVE
COMMUNITY PROGRAMS FOR SUMMER
JOBS.
HE SAID THEY NEED TO BE BUSY AND
NOT ON THE STREETS.
THEY WERE KEPT OUT OF SCHOOL FOR
A YEAR, FOR EXAMPLE, WHAT WAS
THAT ALL ABOUT?
YESTERDAY THE PRESIDENT FOUND A
WAY TO MAKE EVERYBODY MAD SO IF
YOU ARE IN FAVOR OF GUN CONTROL
YOU ARE MAD BECAUSE THERE WAS
NOTHING THERE, IF YOU ARE A
COMMUNITY LEADER WANTING TO WORK
ON THE PROBLEMS IN YOUR
COMMUNITY YOU'RE MAD BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT COMING TO HELP YOU,
WITH THE REPUBLICANS ARE MAD
ABOUT AS THEY ARE NOT TALKING
ABOUT THE ROOT CAUSE, NOW
EVERYBODY IS MAD, WELL DONE.
>> Katie: GOOD JOB, JOE.
B3 THEY OFTEN SET A GREAT LEADER
GETS EVERYBODY PISSED OFF